OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM MISSILE
WHEN YOU CALL THE ROLL BURKE
HERE RALPH HERE CHU GRAY MANSE
MELENDEZ. MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS.
QUIRK HERE RIVAS. TING WE HAVE
A QUORUM. THE CORN NO WAY FRONT
AUTHOR. I'LL KEEP YOU POSTED.
THE STAFF. YEAH OKAY. RIGHT
THERE IS. YEAH. SOMEONE YEAH
ALSO
. WELCOME TO AREA COME ON
AND ME TO FILE ITEM ONE AS HE
TO NINETY FIVE SENATOR IN CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MAN CHAIR. I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE WOMAN INTO THE
COMMITTEE AN APOLOGY I'M SORRY
ABOUT BEING LATE. TRYING TO BE
A TO GET OFF THE FLOOR SO I'M
JUST AND SO APPRECIATIVE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. FIRST I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT THANK YOU
FOR THE CHAIR AND HER
INCREDIBLE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL. THE PAST TWO
DECADES HAVE SEEN A MARKED
INCREASE A WILDFIRE SEVERITY.
THE TWO THOUSAND A WILDFIRE
SEASON ECLIPSED AS THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY THIS
YEAR FOR WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA AND CANDIDLY HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY WILD AND
FIRES ABOUT TAKING PLACE IN THE
LAST DECADE. WITH OVER THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND HOMES AND OTHER
STRUCTURES BEING DESTROYED BY
WILDFIRES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. AS A TWO THOUSAND TEN
CALIFORNIA AT FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION HOMES IN THE WILD AND
URBAN INTERFACE. TOO MANY TWO
MILLION OF THOSE ARE AT A HIGH
OR EXTREME RISK FROM WILDFIRES.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ANALYSIS BY
THERE'S A DATA AND KNOWLEDGE
ANALYTICS FIRM. SOME OF THE
MOST EXPOSED COUNTIES ARE ALSO
THOSE WITH THE LEAST OF ME.
INCLUDING MANY RURAL COUNTIES
AND CANDIDLY HAVE SEEN THAT
FIRSTHAND MY OWN BACKYARD. BOTH
URBAN AND SUBURBAN COUNTIES
ALSO FACE SIGNIFICANT RISK AND
THIS IS WHERE THE BULK OF THE
THREATEN HOMES CURRENTLY EXIST.
FITS TO FIRE HARD HOMES CAN
COST AS MUCH AS THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PUTTING COMMONSENSE
MITIGATION MEASURES OUT OF
REACH FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS
WITHOUT SOME KIND OF STATE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. AND FUNNY
MITIGATION MAKES FISCAL SENSE.
THE FEMA ESTIMATES THAT FOR
EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON FIRE
HARDING MEASURES TO BRING
BUILDINGS UP TO CURRENT CODES
FOR DOLLARS RECEIVED AND THAT
INCLUDES COUNTLESS LIVES
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN PROPERTY
DAMAGE AND HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF AVOID INSURANCE COSTS. IN
CALIFORNIA THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT CAN APPROACH SIX
DOLLARS SIX DOLLARS FOR EACH
DOLLAR OF MITIGATION. WE'RE
MODELING THIS BILL OFF OF THE
VERY SUCCESSFUL BID Là IN
COLORADO THEY PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THAT ALLOWS
HOMEOWNERS TO CLAIM A DEDUCTION
OF ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT EXPENSES.
HOPING LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF
HOMEOWNERS MAINTAIN DEFENSIBLE
SPACE SINCE THE BILL WAS
ORIGINALLY INTRODUCE. THE BILL
CREATED TO TAX CREDIT SYSTEM
FOR QUALIFY TAXPAYERS WHO IN
KERR COSTS WHILE PERFORMING
HOME HARDENING OR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ON THEIR PRIMARY
RESIDENCE. TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE CREDITS ANY HOME HARDENING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT MUST
COMPLY WITH STATE BUILDING
CODES AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS FOR AREAS
VULNERABLE TO WILDFIRE.
ENSURING THAT THESE MEASURES
ARE BACKED BY DATA. TAXPAYERS
CAN GET REIMBURSED. 450% OF THE
COST OF THE ANCHOR TO IMPLEMENT
THESE MEASURES. OF TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR HOME HARDENING
MEASURES IN A THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE NATION MANAGEMENT. WE
WILL ALSO BE AMENDING THE BILL
TO LOWER THE INCOME THRESHOLD
TO SEVENTY THOU SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR INDIVIDUAL IN
FORTY THOUSAND A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR JOINT
FILERS IF. THIS BILL MAKES IT
OUT OF COMMITTEE IN INTO
PREPARATIONS. TO FURTHER
SAFEGUARD TAXPAYERS SB TWO
NINETY FIVE INCLUDES RIGOROUS
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES IT COMPLIES WITH BEST
PRACTICES FOR TAX EXPENDITURES
BY OUTLINES SPECIFIC GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES. IT REQUIRES A
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
REVIEW THE TAX CREDIT INTO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE. AND
IT INCLUDES A SUNSET PROVISION
WHICH I THINK IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REVIEWS A TAX CREDIT. IN FIVE
YEARS AND I WANTED MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CHAIR WHO IS
BEEN SO FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE DELIVERING
DELIVERED. ON THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE INVESTING WHEN IT COMES
TO. TAX CREDITS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH HAVE ME HAVE WITH US TODAY
PAUL SMITH FROM RC RC AND THE
MAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND FROM
SOUTH LAKE TAHOE FIRE
DEPARTMENT. THIS IS CHIEF MET
SEN HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. WE
FEEL THAT THIS ISSUE IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT AND IF YOU IF
YOU'LL LET ME DIGRESS JUST A
BABY BIT. I'VE HAD EXPERIENCES
IS THE FIRST SHE PARTICULAR
WHEN I WAS IN MARIN COUNTY
WHERE WE- TRY TO GET HOMEOWNERS
TO HARDEN THEIR HOMES. AND TO
CUT THEIR WEEKS. AND THE
REALITY IS THAT THAT WAS A VERY
DIFFICULT TASK TO HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED AND ULTIMATELY WE
TOOK HIM THROUGH LITIGATION
PROCESS IT TOOK US NEARLY TWO
YEARS. I TO GET ANYTHING DONE
AND THEN WE HAVE STARTED THE
WHOLE PROCESS AGAIN. SO THE
INCENTIVE CONCERTS CONCEPT
ABOUT DO YOU GET PEOPLE TO DEAL
WITH. DO YOU CATCH BEES WITH
HONEY. CATCHING WITH VINEGAR
REALLY IS KIND OF APPROPRIATE
IN THIS AREA. IN THE BOTTOM
LINE IS IF YOU HARDEN YOUR HOME
AND YOU. TAKE CARE OF YOUR FUEL
MANAGEMENT. I YOU'RE PROTECTING
YOUR NEIGHBORS HOMES AS WELL WE
LOOK AT THESE LARGE URBAN
CONFLAGRATIONS CALIFORNIA
CERTAINLY AT THE LEADER AND
THAT AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE NOT VERY PROUD OF. WE
SHOULD BE THE LEADER AND WHILE
FIRE. AND WE SHOULD BE THE
LEADERS IN MITIGATION SO. I
WOULD URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THAT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS INCENTIVES
WORK FOR PEOPLE. IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE TO HARD YOUR HOME AND
THE BOTTOM LINE IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE. JUST DON'T DO IT
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT WE
THINK THIS MAKES SENSE. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAUL SMITH
WITH RC RC ALSO KNOWN AS THE
RURAL COUNTIES ASSOCIATION AS
YOU PROBABLY KNOW MOST OF OUR
MEMBER COUNTIES ARE GROUND ZERO
FOR THE WILD FIRE PROBLEM. THE
WELFARE DEBATE AND PARTICULARLY
THE WILDFIRES STRUCTURE LOSS.
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE CAMPFIRE AND
BUTTE CAR FIRE AND SHASTA THE
NUMEROUS FIRES IN LEE COUNTY
THAT CENTER REQUIRES EXPERIENCE
IN RECENT YEARS. THESE HAVE ALL
BEEN COUNTIES WITH INCREDIBLE
AMOUNTS OF RESIDENTIAL
STRUCTURE LOSS. WE BELIEVE THE
ONE OF THE BUSINESS BIGGEST
TOOLS WE CAN HAVE IT TO
MINIMIZE STRUCTURE LOST IS
DEFENSIBLE SPACE HOME
HARDENING. MANY OF OUR COUNTIES
ARE GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF NOT ONLY ADOPTING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE ORDINANCES BUT AND
FORCING THEM I THINK IS THE
CHIEF BIG EXPLAIN JUST A MOMENT
AGO JUST HOW DIFFICULT THIS IS.
SO WE SEE SB TWO NINETY FIVE IS
AN APPROPRIATE TOOL TO GET SOME
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE FOR. THOSE
INDIVIDUALS PARTICULARLY THOSE
OF LOWER INCOME. AND DO NOT
HAVE OBVIOUSLY THE CASH FLOW OR
THE UP FRONT MONIES TO DO THIS
TYPE OF WORK WE SEE THIS BILL
AS A VERY KEY PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION. AND AGAIN. AND
MANY OF OUR MEMBER COUNTIES THE
INCOME LEVEL IS JUST SO
DIFFICULT AND THIS IS WHY AGAIN
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE TOOL WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASSES
AND QUITE FRANKLY THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THIS. ONE
OF THE KEY ASPECTS OF.
MITIGATING THE WHILE FIRED
THREAT THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON LARGER
MEMO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA. OF CERTAIN THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT INSURANCE AGENTS
AND BROKERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION I
DO WANT TO SAY WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE WITH THE MANY
ASPECTS THAT ARE PUT INTO THE
MEASURE REGARDING SEND SIX SIX
CETERA THAT WE'VE BEEN ADDED
VACATING FOR WHILE ALSO WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR PAYING AT
PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO THAT WE
ARE VERY MUCH DO APPRECIATE IT
THE REASON WE SUPPORT DON'T
SUPPORT THE MEASURE IS THAT IT
WOULD POTENTIALLY CUT UP TO ONE
POINT TWO FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
FROM OUR SCHOOLS.MONEY THAT
WOULD HAVE GONE TO KIDS THE
NEXT THREE YEARS SO WE DO VERY
MUCH TO BELIEVE SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE DONE IF IT'S THE PRIORITY
ON THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
BELIEVES THAT IT IS THEN WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT OTHER
TAX CREDITS OR OTHER ITEMS THAT
ARE OUT THERE AND THAT MIGHT
NOT GIVE YOU THE SAME RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IN THE SAME BENEFIT
TO CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE AND WE
WOULD ASK YOU TO USE AN
ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF FUNDING.
FOR AN EXAMPLE THIS WOULD ALSO
HAVE AN IMPACT ON OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE IN HIGH HIGH
PRONE FIRE AREAS OF AS WELL I
SPEND A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME THIS YEAR ADVOCATING TO
GET IT A THIRD YOU. ARE EIGHTY
A FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS IN
PARADISE. DESPITE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME ON THAT AND WE
THINK THEY EVEN THE THREE YEARS
ISN'T GOING TO BE ENOUGH FOR
PARADISE TO. BUILD BECAUSE THEY
CAN EVEN REBUILD OUR SCHOOLS
COMPREHENSIVELY. UNTIL IT
COUNTY KIDS ALL THE MYRIAD OF
FOUNDATIONAL SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES TAKING CARE OF SO WE
IN THE- SCHOOL SYSTEM ARE ALSO.
HAVING TO SUFFER FROM THE
RESULT OF WILDFIRES BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT TAKING RESOURCES
AWAY FROM SCHOOLS. THEY NEED TO
ACTUALLY. PROVIDE SERVICES TO
KIDS AND BUILD OUR OWN-FACILITIES SO WE CAN WITHSTAND
FIRE OR ALSO ISSUES THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED SO. WITH THIS
IS A COMPLICATED ISSUE AND WE
ARE VERY SENSITIVE ABOUT BUT WE
DO ASK THAT SCHOOLS ARE NOT
HARMED IN THE PROCESS OF THESE
LONG TERM SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SCENE NINE COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE TALKED QUIRK. SO I
HAVE A COUPLE PROBLEMS ONE IS.
AT LEAST AT THE TIME OF THE
WRITING OF THE ANALYSIS IN THE
MAY HAVE CHANGED IT'S NOT A
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT WHICH
MEANS THE 50% OF PEOPLE IN THE
STATE WHO DON'T PAY STATE TAXES
GET NO BENEFIT. THESE ARE ALSO
LOWER INCOME. AND I REALIZE
THIS WOULD ALSO MAKE THE BILL
MORE EXPENSIVE BUT PERHAPS YOU
HAVE TO THEN LOWER THE. THREE
INCOME LEVELS IT WHICH YOU
TOGETHER BENEFIT BUT FRANKLY
THE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T PAY STATE
TAXES ARE BECAUSE OF BEING OF
LOW INCOME AND THESE ARE THE
ONES WHO NEED THE HELP THE MOST
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ABOUT
THAT ANY REFLECTIONS ON WHAT
YOU MIGHT DO. NO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS AN EVER AT THROUGH THE
CHAIR AT SOME MEMBER QUIRK
BRINGS UP A REALLY GOOD POINT
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LOW INCOME
OR ON FIXED INCOME IS WELL AS
THOSE WHO ARE MIDDLE CLASS. WE
DID NOT FOCUS ON THE LOW INCOME
OR THOSE SENIORS WHO ARE ON
FIXED INCOME TWO REASONS ONE
ASSUME NUMBER WOULD HAS A
REALLY GREAT BILL THAT IS HAS
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD IT'S A
ONE BILLION DOLLAR REVOLVING
LOAN FUND THAT WOULD BE FOCUS
ON THOSE LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
THAT ARE LIVING WITHIN. HI FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY SOUNDS. SENATOR
RUBIO ALSO HAS A MEASURE THAT'S
BEEN FOCUS ON LOW INCOME AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ON FIXED
INCOMES. THE INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNERS BETWEEN SEVENTY
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND YEAR WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR THE
REVOLVING LOAN FUND OR CENTER
RUBIO IS LEGISLATION. AND WHAT
WE KNOW IS THE MAJORITY OF
HOMES WITH IN THAT HI FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITIES OWNS THOSE
VERY ZONES OUR MIDDLE INCOME.
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE ADVANCING
THE TAX CREDIT. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SAY THIS HAS TO BE PART
OF A LARGER PICTURE. AND YOU'RE
GONNA SEE ADDITIONAL PIECES OF
LEGISLATION ON TO WEATHER
FRONTS. NUMBER ONE WE NEED TO
TAKE A DATA DRIVEN APPROACH
ABOUT HOW WE'RE MAKING
INVESTMENTS WHETHER IT'S THE
REVOLVING LOAN FUND IS A MEMBER
WOOD OR TAX CREDIT WHICH MEANS
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE IS
GETTING. THE DATE EVERY YEAR ON
NON RENEWALS. THEY DON'T
INSURANCE COMPANIES DON'T.
DON'T CURRENTLY. HAVE A MANDATE
TO BE TO PROVIDE THE NON
RENEWAL INFORMATION ON ANNUAL
BASIS TO THE PART INSURANCE. WE
BELIEVE THAT HAS TO BE A MUST.
THAT WAY WE'RE ABLE TO FIGURE
OUT WHICH AREAS OF THE STATE.
ARE LOSING INSURANCE THE
FASTEST. THEN YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE REVOLVING LOAN
FUND AND TAX CREDITS TO BE TO
TAKE CARE NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITY. DOING ONE HOUSE AT
IT I WILL NOT MAKE OF COMMUNITY
MORE FIRE SAFE IT'S TAKING
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. AND WE HAVE TO DO
THAT WITH DATA WHICH WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE. IN ADDITION
YOU'RE GONNA SEE LEGISLATION
THAT WILL BE AN- THAT FOCUS ON
TRUNCATING THE TIME. FOR CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHEN IT
COMES A FIRE SAFETY AND PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC PROPERTY. I'M IT
COULD BE SIX MONTHS TO TWO
YEARS TO BE A TO MITIGATE A
PRIVATE OR PUBLIC PROPERTY.
WHEN IT COMES TO FIRE RISK
THAT'S RIDICULOUS. WE ALSO NEED
TO GET CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND FIRE MARSHALS. THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PUT SOME SUGAR ON THE TABLE TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
FIRE STATE. SO THAT IS WHY. WE
DID NOT WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ENTER INTO THE SPACE OF THE SIM
NUMBER WOULDN'T BECAUSE HE HAS
A WONDERFUL PLAN. AND WE FULLY
SUPPORT THAT. AND WHAT WE ALSO
KNOW THERE ARE GOING TO BE
LITERALLY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. IN TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOMES THAT WOULD
NOT QUALIFY FOR THAT REVOLVING
LOAN FUND. AND THAT'S WHY YOU
SEE S. FOCUSING ON THAT AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ALSO NEARING
IT DOWN. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ANSWER THE ISSUE OF
LOCKS TAX REVENUE. I'LL SAY IS
THAT. THE CITY AND ROSA CITY
SCHOOLS. I THEY'VE LOST SEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS SEVEN HUNDRED
AND OVER THREE THOUSAND FOLKS
OF LESSON ON THE COUNTY. OVER
THE LAST NEARLY TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS. WE HAVE FOUGHT HARD TO
BE ABLE TO BACKFILL THEIR
GENERAL FUND. WE TAKE A LOOK AT
SOME OF THE LONGEST AND LARGEST
LOSSES OF TO OF PROPERTY TAX
IT'S WHEN THESE MASSIVE FIRES
WIPE OUT ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOODS
IN ROLES. IN NASSAU WERE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY TAX.
REDUCTIONS IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
GENERATION IN CINEMA COUNTY TO
BE A TO GET BACK TO WHERE THEY
WERE IN THE CITY SANTA ROSA IT
MAY TAKE LONGER. IN THE COUNTY
OF LAKE AND THE REASON WHY I
BRING THAT UP IS THAT WE CAN'T
AFFORD NOT TO BE A TO BRING
THIS FORWARD WE NEED A
STRATEGIC APPROACH. MULTIPLE
TOOLS IN THE BELT AND THAT IS
WHY WE'RE BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND IF WE CAN GIVE OVER TEN.
BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX CREDITS
TO CORPORATIONS IN THE STATE WE
SURE AS HELL CAN GIVE IT TO
HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS TO BE
TO MAKE THEIR FOR THEIR HOMES
FIRE SAFE I'M SORRY YEP DON
SOME NUMBER OF BUT IT. IS A
GREAT QUESTION REALLY THERE WAS.
A GOOD ANSWER. MY CONCERN IS.
THE WAY THAT IS HIGH PRAISE
FROM HIM YEAH. MY CONCERN IS
NOW WE'RE SAYING IF YOU'RE LOW
INCOME TO GET A LOAN IF YOU
HAVE. HIGH INCOME YOU GET FREE
MONEY. AND THAT JUST DOESN'T
WORK FOR ME. YOU'RE TREATING
THE HIGHER INCOME PEOPLE BETTER
THAN YOUR TREATING THE LOWER
INCOME PEOPLE. THAT'S MY
CONCERN. I MEAN WE COULD
DEVELOP A LARGER LOAN PROGRAM
BUT I THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE EXPENSE OF THAT AN IMPACT
ON THE GENERAL FUND WILL BE
EVEN MORE SIGNIFICANT BUT AGAIN
IF THIS LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO
STEP UP AND STAND TALL FOR THE
LARGEST CORPORATIONS ON THE
PLANET. AND GIVE THEM TAX
BREAKS THEN WE BETTER IS HELD
STEP UP AND PROVIDE THEM FOR
HOMEOWNERS IN IN THE REASON WHY
I SAY THAT IS THAT THIS IS ONE
OF THE BEST WAYS THAT WE CAN
INSURE FIRE SAFETY BUT I HEAR
YOU AND I RESPECT YOUR OPINION
AND YOU ARE ONE OF THE
SMARTEST. INDIVIDUALS IN THE
LEGISLATURE I KNOW WE MAY
DISAGREE ON THIS BUT YEAH I
GREATLY RESPECT YOUR OPINION.
THANK YOU. MR GRAY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR AGENCY. THE BILL THAT
YOU BROUGHT HERE TODAY AND MY
COMMENTS ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE OF FORCE OF THAT
I THINK MAKES A GREAT DEAL OF
SENSE TO GIVE SOME INCENTIVES
TO HARDEN AND REDUCE SOME OF
THIS RISK ON THE MACRO LEVEL
I'M WELL AWARE OF THE
DIFFICULTY AS RELATIONSHIP AND
SAYS I HAVE A PROPERTY WITH MY
FAMILY IN THE FOOTHILLS OF
PREMIER POSER REGION AND WE'VE
SEEN OUR HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
GO FROM ROUGHLY FOURTEEN HER
DOLLARS YEAR FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR IN ONE YEAR. SO
THAT'S GOING TO BE A PROBLEM
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO GET
OUR ARMS AROUND GOING FORWARD
BUT AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF SUCH
CALIFORNIA AND NORTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY ONE OF THE
THINGS I'VE SAID WITH ALMOST
EVERYONE OF THESE BILLS BEFORE
EVERY COMMITTEE AND ON THE
FLOOR IS THERE SEEMS. TO BE OR
FEELS AS IF THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A. FOR CALLING PARKS
EITHER PERHAPS SAY. A SENSE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO IGNORE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES OF OTHER
STATES WE HAVE FOLKS THAT
REPRESENT DISTRICTS WHERE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS CREATING
PERHAPS A PROPENSITY FOR
INCREASES IN FIRE RISK WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THIS HOW DO WE PROVIDE
SOME BLANKET SECURITY. WALT
HOMES OR COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE WE HAVE
INCREASINGLY HOT CLIMATES.
HISTORICALLY WE'VE ALWAYS HAD
OUR CLIMATE JUST AS
HISTORICALLY PORTIONS YOUR
DISTRICT ANOTHER HAVE ALWAYS
HAD WILD FIRES. AND AS WE SEE
INCREASES IN BOTH IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO
THE ENERGY RATE INCREASES ON MY
CONSTITUENTS. SO IT'S LIKE
SHARING IS CARING WHEN IT COMES
TO WILD FIRES. AND LET'S SPREAD
THE RISK AND THAT'S ALL PAY AND
LET'S ALL HELP OUT. BUT
MEANWHILE THE PARADE A BILL
WHICH WAS A RATE YOU KNOW.
RESTRUCTURING BILL FROM TWENTY.
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY FOURTEEN
STILL HASN'T BEEN ABLE
IMPLEMENTED WERE TWENTY
NINETEEN AND WE INCREASINGLY
SEE. SIGNIFICANT HIKES IN
ENERGY RATES AND TIERED RATE
STRUCTURES FOR FOLKS IN THE
CENTER ALLEN OTHER HOT CLIMATE
SO WHAT WHILE I'M SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY AND CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROVIDE THE TOOLS AND
THE SUPPORT FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS I WOULD HOPE THAT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD YOURSELF.
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD BEGIN TO HAVE SOME EQUAL
CAN EARN AN ATTENTION. TO THE
VERY REAL ISSUE THEY SAID. SOME
OF THE POOREST COMMUNITIES. IN
THE STATE WHICH RESIDE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. SUPPORT TODAY
AND CERTAINLY LOOK TO SUPPORT
IT AS IT MOVES FORWARD BUT
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
IN ELEVATING AND REYES IN THOSE
ISSUES TO OUR COLLEAGUES. THE
TERM WHICH WOULD BE OKAY. LOOK
AT THE SOMEONE NUMBER BRINGS UP
REALLY GOOD POINTS. BEING FULLY
TRANSPARENT WE'VE BEEN ASKED IF
WE COULD EXPAND THIS INCLUDING
BOLTING OF HOMES FOR
EARTHQUAKES. I WOULD LOVE TO BE
ABLE TO TALK WITH YOU MORE
ABOUT THIS IF THAT WOULD BE
OKAY AND WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO
SET SOME TIME ON AT SOME OF
YOUR IDEAS I THINK ON THIS
ISSUE THIS CAN BE COMPLETELY
CANDID WITH A COMMITTEE AND THE
CHAIR. I THINK THAT ULTIMATELY
WHAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO
IS LOOK AT A PILOT PROJECT THAT
COULD BE ADVANCE IN THIS STATE
THAT CAN BE FOCUSED ON WILDFIRE
MULTIPLE TOOLS IN THE BALLOT AS
WE JUST DISCUSSED THIS IN THE
REPORT. AND. SOME OF OUR GREAT
YOU BRING UP SOME WONDERFUL
POINTS THAT IT GOES WELL
BEYOND. WILDFIRES IN THOSE
ISSUES EXIST PRIOR TO THIS
CRISIS IN THE STATE I WOULD. BE
WILLING TO IN MORE THAN WILLING
IN IN HELP YOU BE WILLING TO
SIT DOWN. AND TALK FURTHER
ABOUT THAT IF THAT BE OKAY.
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE IT AND
YEAH I THINK THAT WE MAY FIND
THE ANSWER TO ALL OF OUR
QUESTIONS IN WORKING TOGETHER.
ON A LARGER SCALE THAT'S NOT
FOR TODAY'S COMMITTEE HEARING
BUT CERTAINLY. SOME WE SHOULD
SIT DOWN TALK ABOUT. YOU'LL
HEAR FROM US THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIMILAR I'M GRATEFUL. THANK
YOU. SO IN MEMORY OF US DID YOU.
THANK YOU. ARE YOU TO JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO THE CREEK FIRE.
HAPPEN IN MY DISTRICT AND OUR
COMMUNITY IS STILL. ON
RECOVERING FROM THIS FIRE AND
I'VE HEARD FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS. ABOUT THIS SO I
THINK THIS IS. THE HOME
HARDENING AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ARE GREAT WAYS. TO
HELP. ALL OF THE- VICTIMS OF
THESE WILDFIRES AND TO PREVENT.
HOMES FROM. BEING BURNED. AND
AROUND THE SAME TIME THAT THAT
FIRE WAS GOING ON I KNOW THERE
WAS A- FIRE IN. IN YOUR
DISTRICT SENATOR. AND RUMOR HAS
IT THAT WHEN YOU HEARD THAT.
HOME OF A LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIAL. WAS BURNING YOU
PERSONALLY WHEN IN. I'M TO SAVE
SOME MEMENTOS. ON FOR THAT
PERSON SO I WHEN I COMMEND YOU.
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND TO THIS ISSUE.
SO THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I AM VERY GRATEFUL THAT
WAS A- HELL OF A NIGHT I WILL
SHARE TIA AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL
THANK YOU. NUMBER TING. THANK
YOU SIR FOR THE BILL JUST.
STERN IN TERMS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS REGARDING THE TAX
CREDIT OBVIOUSLY WEEK THIS IS
IN A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE WE
DEFINITELY DO WANT PEOPLE TO DO
BETTER IN TERMS OF VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT MAKING SURE THERE
ARE HOMES ARE FIRE RESISTANT ON
THE ANALYSIS PLAY NOT WHETHER
OR NOT THIS WOULD ACTUALLY
REALLY. INCENTIVIZE BEHAVIOR OR
WE JUST GIVING MONEY TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE GOING TO ALREADY DO
THIS ANYWAYS CITY OF THE SENSOR
DIFFERENT GIVE ANY KIND OF.
STUDY OR ANY DATA THAT THAT
WHAT'S MOVE US IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER NIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER TING WHAT I CAN I CAN'T
SHARE WITH YOU DATA ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL BUT I CAN SHARE
WITH YOU DATA WITH IN CINEMA
MENDOCINO LAKE COUNTIES. WHILE
THERE IS A MANDATE FOR
HOMEOWNERS TO BE ABLE. TO
ADVANCE DEFENSIBLE SPACE AS
WELL AS HOME HARDENING. THERE
ARE SEVERAL REASONS FOR THAT
ESPECIALLY. THROUGHOUT THE
FIELD AND IT'S AN ISSUE OF
MEANS. SO I REPLACE IN A ROOF
IS INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE AND
BEING ABLE TO PUT A MANDATE ON
TO THEM AS A CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL ESPECIALLY THE
BACKLOG. IS SIMPLY AREN'T
MOVING ON THAT. SO THAT'S WHY I
BELIEVE THIS NEED TO BE PART OF
A LARGER PROGRAM NUMBER ONE WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET.
MANDATED DATA TO THE APARTMENT
INSURANCE FOR NON RENEWALS. TWO
WE NEED TO BE A LOOK AT THE
COUNTIES THAT HAVE THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF NON RENEWALS WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE THAT RIGHT NOW. THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN GO OFF OF WHERE
INSURANCE BEING LOSS IS GOING
TO FOR FAIR PLAN NUMBERS. THREE
WE NEED A- BONE FORSMAN
OFFICERS. WITH AN EXPEDITED
TIMELINE S WE JUST HEARD FROM
THE CHIEF COULD PAY TAKE TWO
YEARS. TO GET AN INDIVIDUAL TO
THE PROCESS. TO ACTUALLY
ENFORCE THE LAW. I BELIEVE THAT
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT
NINETY DAYS THAT'S GONNA BE
CONTROVERSIAL. AND THOSE CONE
FORCING OFFICERS RATHER THAN
JUST THROWING. A HAMMER IT
FOLKS THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE TOOLS. AND THAT'S WHERE WE
BRING. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOME
NUMBER WOODS INVOLVING LONG
FINE. FOR THOSE WHO ARE LOW
INCOME ON FIXED. INCOME AND
THERE IS A REBATE PROGRAM IN
THAT FOR THE THOSE OR THE
LOWEST OF LOW INCOME. AS WELL
AS HELP THOSE WERE MIDDLE
CLASS. I WILL WORK AS A MEMBER
TING ON STATEWIDE NUMBERS I
DON'T HAVE THAT ON ME TODAY AND
I DON'T WANT TO. BE SCA HEARING
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING AND I AND
I TO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THIS BILL I DO THINK THAT
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE
HARDENED AND I THINK IN
COMPLEMENT WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER BILLS THAT ARE MOVING
THROUGH THE PROCESS WHICH WE
DID REVIEW AS PART OF REVIEWING
YOUR MEASURE. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE OF ALL
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS ARE ABLE
TO HARDEN THEIR HOMES AND TO
THE OPPOSITION IN THIS ONE CASE
I WILL I WILL ACTUALLY I FEEL
DIFFERENTLY ON THIS ONE I WENT
TO SCHOOL IN PARADISE THERE WAS
ACTUALLY SAVED AS A RESULT OF
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
HARDENING AND THAT SCHOOL IN
THOSE STUDENTS. IT'S THE ONE
NORMAL THING THEY HAVE BECAUSE
THE PROPERTY WAS HARDENED AND
BECAUSE VEGETATION MANAGER WAS
DONE THEY GET TO STILL GO TO
SCHOOL EVERY DAY AND IT'S THE
ONE THING THAT THEY HAVE TO
RETURN TO REGULARLY AND THAT
WAS FROM THEIR PREVIOUS LIFE
AND I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT SO I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
NOT JUST THE HOMES ARE HARDENED
BUT THAT ALL THE IMPORTANT
PROPERTIES IN THE COMMUNITY OUR
OUR OUR CAT MAINTAINED AND KEPT
SAFE AND WHETHER THAT'S A
HOSPITAL OR A SCHOOL I AGREE
WITH YOU WE NEED TO EXTEND
THESE PROGRAMS TO THOSE FOLKS
AS WELL BUT I THINK THAT THE
DAMAGE AND THE LOSS FROM
PROPERTY TAXES FROM.
DEVASTATING THESE COMMUNITIES I
DEFINITELY SAW THAT AS WELL AND
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WITH THE
LOCALS AND SO FOR ME THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE MAKING SURE
YOU COMMUNITIES ARE HARDENED IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT NEEDS
MEANS. ANY CONTINUE TO BE A
PRIORITY OF. THIS LEGISLATURE
WITH THAT. YOU HAVE IN IRAQ
WHICH LEFT. HMM THANK YOU FOR
WORKING. AS PLEASE IT IS AN
ABSOLUTE. PLEASURE AND I'M NOT
JUST SAYING THAT BECAUSE I'M IN
FRONT OF YOU. SEARCH FOR. VERY
GRATEFUL AND WOULD APPRECIATE
YOU KNOW I. THINK YOU WITH THAT
MISSILE WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE
HI BRO. BRO I CHU CHU AYE GRAY.
I MAYES MULLIN THIS WINDESHEIM
MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS. QUIRK
RIVAS RIVAS I'D TING TING ON.
SO THAT MEASURES OUT SEVEN ZERO
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE BUT WE
WILL HOLD COMMITTEE OPEN FOR
FIVE MINUTES. THANK YOU
. MULLIN
ARE HIGH. THANK YOU
. CALLING
THE ABSENTEES SB TWO NINETY
FIVE PETRIE-NORRIS. YOUR SITE
.
WITH HIGHLY KALIAN CITIES SB
TWO NINETY FIVE MAYES MAYES
EVERYONE. WE ARE ADJOURNED